boa tarde pessoal eu queria começar
pedindo pra vocês fecharem os olhos por
um segundo e mentalizarem a palavra casa
qual é o sentimento sensação que vem à
cabeça de vocês
normalmente têm uma relação de conforto
de segurança e do ano passado estava em
brasília e eu fui numa exposição design
gráfico e eu me deparei com essa
ilustração e esse pequeno poema muito
simples que diz minha própria casa minha
jornada
esse poeminha ele foi escrito no século
17 por um dos maiores e mais importante
poeta japonês chamado matsuo bashô esse
cara ele era professor
ele vivia onde atualmente a cidade de
tóquio e depois de um certo tempo na
vida dele ele resolveu abrir mão das
rodas literárias e dos círculos sociais
da cidade e inicia uma série de
peregrinações pelo país
a sua obra é uma das mais importantes
para o país é muito reflexo dessas
experiências dessas vivências que ele
teve durante esse tempo esse tempo
esse pequeno poema me impactou de uma
forma muito grande porque ele resume em
algumas poucas palavras o sentimento que
eu estava sentindo naquele momento
naquele momento com relação à minha
própria significado de casa porque 18
meses
essa jornada tem sido a minha casa nos
últimos 18 meses
eu vivi em 61 cidades em 19 países
nos últimos 18 meses
essa única mala tem sido minha casa nos
últimos 18 meses
essas têm sido apenas algumas das 104
casas que eu vivi
então pergunto pra vocês que muda no
significado e no sentimento da palavra
casa depois de um curto espaço de tempo
teve vivido em mais de 100 casas
diferente do que acontece quando você
diz constrói essa noção tão sólida e tão
forte e tão emocional que a gente tem na
vida
será que como diz a música a casa é um
sentimento que a gente leva pra qualquer
lugar que a gente vai bem preciso dizer
que antes desses 18 meses até o início
do ano passado
eu provavelmente com a maioria de vocês
aqui eu morava numa casa
eu morava no rio de janeiro no
apartamento com meu marido é cheio de
imóveis cheio de objetos e éramos muito
felizes lá mas já havíamos um tempo é
transformando as nossas relações
profissionais nós temos background
completamente diferentes
eu fui durante muito tempo professor
universitário era é funcionária pública
e ele tinha uma agência de comunicação
nós então resolvemos trabalhar juntos
viram os sócios
criamos uma coisa que não existia que é
uma consultoria com foco no mercado de
entretenimento e nós já estávamos
trabalhando juntos no rio nesse
apartamento em casa
uma parte do tempo de home office a
gente queria viajar mais
a gente queria passar um tempo aqui em
são paulo e queria passar um tempo em
são francisco por que não passar um
tempo em bancoc
só que a conta não batia né você viajar
e você está pagando uma despesa de um
aluguel de um condomínio em uma cidade
cara como rio de janeiro
as duas coisas não tinham sentido a
gente começou a pensar foi sentido a
gente tá aqui vivendo da forma que está
vivendo isso está sendo bom pra gente do
ponto de vista pessoal profissional ou a
gente está simplesmente repetindo um
padrão que foi ensinado pra gente quer
assim que tinha que ser
é nos nossos cursos e os nossos clientes
falava muito sobre criatividade né
é aquele tipo de coisa é muito fácil
falar para o outro fazer né
a criatividade é o que você pratica no
dia a dia que você tem que fazer
diferente você tem que sair da zona de
conforto
você tem que provocar e no final do dia
a gente continua fazendo tudo do mesmo
jeito né porque todo mundo quer inovar
mas ninguém quer correr risco é verdade
então nós resolvemos correr risco e aí
em março do ano passado a gente vendeu e
doou praticamente tudo que nós tínhamos
alguns poucos objetos de valor muito
emocional mas colocamos no pequeno
depósito no rio e passamos a viver cada
um de nós uma única mala
esses 18 meses têm sido de grande
reflexão pra gente porque nós não
fazemos ideia não só de questões
práticas do tipo aonde eu vou lavar
minha roupa mas de questões é reflexivas
e filosóficas importante para a vida da
gente do tipo que está por trás de uma
pergunta tão banal que normalmente faz
pessoas quando a gente acaba de
conhecê-las que você faz
onde você mora será que está preparado
para ouvir uma resposta diferente do
padrão né
então eu falo que hoje tudo que eu vou
responder começa uma história
não consigo mais responder uma coisa que
eu não tenho endereço
eu não tenho uma profissão eu estou
fazendo um monte de coisas e eu estou
hoje nesse lugar né
quando a gente começou esse movimento
as pessoas falavam cara vocês são loucos
ou vocês ganharam na mega sena
ou a vida de vocês é maravilhosa o
menino nem outro têm dores têm delícias
e como qualquer escolha na vida não é
melhor nem pior
mas é uma escolha consciente então eu
falo que o que a gente está vivendo hoje
é na verdade um grande experimento que
começaram se com três meses e já viraram
18 e é um experimento de que é um
experimento de viver trabalhar e nos
relacionar no fluxo e repetindo a
palavra fluxo aqui com outro sentido que
a gente deu porque para a gente melhorar
o que está fazendo não é um sabático não
é férias mas é uma tentativa de gerar
dinheiro
produtivo trabalhar nos mantermos sãos e
saudáveis
no que a gente chama de fluxo o fluxo
pra gente é o movimento é a inconstância
é o desconforto
o fluxo para a gente esse lugar que a
gente transita que a gente não sabe
dizer se nós somos moradores se somos
turistas
a gente está visitando a gente está
trabalhando a gente está viajando
o fluxo para a gente é toda essa
provocação de sair desse espaço binário
que até então foi construído para nós
então o fluxo ea gente se sentir
confortável e não ter explicação sobre
coisas que historicamente precisaria ter
uma explicação mas é do tipo vamos
pensar sobre isso
o que você pensa sobre isso na verdade
em vez de você vem com uma resposta
padrão
o fluxo é esse espaço em que nós
deixamos de ser sedentários e nos
tornamos nomes né
e aí eu queria só abre um parêntese para
falar que quando eu falo o nome de e eu
não tô falando de uma categoria de
nomadismo compulsório não é quem é
muitas pessoas são obrigadas a deixar
suas casas os lugares onde vivem em
função de conflitos de mudanças
climáticas
estou falando aqui de um uma outra
categoria
e aí eu encontrei muita resposta porque
eu estava sentindo e portanto porque o
que eu estava vivendo
lendo esse livro do filósofo francês
michel matheus oliva que o livro já tem
um nome maravilhoso né que é sobre o
nomadismo vagabundagem pós modernas e aí
quando eu peguei o livro falei pô cara
tá falando que eu sou vagabunda né
eu não quero trabalhar eu tô falando
justamente o oposto que este é um espaço
de produção também
e quando ele fala de vagabundagem ele
está sempre falando no sentido literal
da palavra vagabundo que é o que se
movimenta o andarilho né
e não há o sentido pejorativo que a
gente entende aqui na língua portuguesa
foi poxa esse cara tá falando algo que
está me tocando porque ele fala de
nomadismo não apenas fruto de uma
necessidade mas fruto de uma
folha de um desejo de uma inquietação ea
i am
ele vai muito mais além que ele fala que
esse essa necessidade ela é tão grande
que você muitas vezes não consegue
explicar
então quando o caetano veloso
maravilhosamente bem né coloca na música
você tem que saber que eu quero correr
mundo
eu quero ir embora e ele está
expressando de uma forma metafórica é
claro esse desejo pela mudança é esse
desejo pelo movimento esse desejo de
romper com uma regra para estabelecido
esse desejo de uma certa mudança mas
quando o caetano fala que ele quer tocar
fogo no apartamento né e ir embora ele
traz e se de uma metáfora muito forte
embora de onde né e que embora pra onde
então é essa ânsia é porque é
simplesmente não é uma pirraça de botar
uma mochila nas costas vou sair vagando
pelo mundo
na verdade historicamente a humanidade
ela foi domesticada né nós deixamos de
ser nômades planos de tornar seres
sedentários uma série de mudanças ali
principalmente na europa entre o século
15 século 18 e no restante do mundo um
pouco mais tardio trouxeram mudanças
muito drástica na maneira como a gente
vive né
a gente deixou de ser agente que digo
humanidade deixamos de ser ver no campo
pra viver na cidade
passamos de uma economia agrária para
uma economia industrializada esse
período histórico conhecido como
modernidade ele trancafiou de pessoas
eles nos trancou em cidades nos tranco
em casas nos tranquilos fábricas
talvez em escolas e nos trancou até
instituições sociais como o casamento
pré-definido
então hoje mais do que nunca a gente
está vivendo essas quebras
a gente está lidando com essas rupturas
o sedentário das ideias fixas que não
muda das posições fixas para um modo de
vida nômade e a ideia que eu gosto muito
da do nomadismo é sobre uma não fixação
e aí eu não estou falando apenas de uma
não fixação de espaço né
ela não fixação de profissão hoje você
pode transitar entre diferentes
trabalhos você pode transitar entre
diferentes empregos você pode transitar
inúmeras possibilidades ao longo da vida
a gente fala eu brinco que eu falo que
profissão hoje não é ser né está a gente
está falando uma não fixação de
identidade
mais que nunca o feminismo por exemplo
está ensinando pra mim eu acredito que
para muitas mulheres que nós temos
infinitas possibilidades de identidade
para além daquela mãe esposa ou a gente
pode fazer o que quiser família modelos
não fixos de família né inúmeras
possibilidades se relacionar se amar te
afeto independente do modelo que ele tem
a não fixação de gênero né então a gente
tá quebrando com todos esses modelos
fixos e dentários e nos tornando nome
disse
e aí eu faço nesse momento eu coloquei
esta foto porque eu acho que muitos de
vocês já devem estar desapontados com a
minha fala porque talvez vocês esperavam
que eu fosse mostrar que um filho cheio
de fotos lindas de lugares exóticos e
contar pra vocês como viajar o mundo e
ganhar dinheiro não vai rolar eu pois
essa foto para ver se aliviava um
pouquinho porque na verdade a viagem é
só o como o mais importante é o porquê
porque eu não quero ter uma casa porque
eu quero ser nômade porque eu quero
criar rupturas e ser nome de rompê é
criar rupturas no nosso caso a gente
tinha uma ruptura muito grande para
criar que a nossa ruptura de trabalho e
nossa ruptura de casa a gente queria ir
além daquilo que a gente tinha naquele
momento então
como que a gente fez essa ruptura a
nossa ruptura o nosso nomadismo ele tem
a ver com o espírito desterritorializar
isso pra nós o que é sair do nosso lugar
de conforto e sair do lado de fora do
furacão sabe que você conseguir enxergar
as coisas de uma outra perspectiva sair
do nosso lugar da nossa casa da nossa
cidade nos permite olhar com olhar de
estrangeiro o tempo todo
nós temos uma máxima que é a gente
chegou no lugar começou a ficar
confortável começou a ficar gostoso a
gente já tem um café preferido já
conhece a caixa do supermercado cara tá
na hora de ir embora
não dá não pode ficar aqui não pode se
acostumar com esse lugar
então o nosso processo é de se
movimentar e quando eu falei lá no
início que o experimento
eu sou um cientista tem uma formação de
cientistas então eu vou acertar sempre
voltando às minhas hipóteses para saber
se experimenta funcionando ou não né
em 18 meses que estou testando ele do
ponto de vista de trabalho e que é uma
das coisas mais importantes para a gente
sair do nosso território nos permitiu
conhecer outros territórios e daí a
gente teve que inventar coisas para
transitar nesses territórios então nós
inventamos um curso itinerante do ano
passado
nós moramos em todas as cidades do
brasil
criamos um curso para empreendedores é
do treinamento profissionais do
entretenimento
vivemos a cidade nos conectamos que
essas pessoas aprendemos coisas cada uma
dessas realidades e hoje nós somos uma
rede de mais de 300 profissionais super
ativos que se conversa o tempo todo
trocam trabalho trocam informação trocam
saberes
a gente precisou inventar coisas que
também fizessem sentido dentro da lógica
que a gente estava vivendo
então nós criamos um projeto de conteúdo
e viagem que é o que a gente acredita
que tem tudo a ver com a gente de levar
pessoas para lisboa
fizemos outro em barcelona então o nosso
desafio é o tempo todo tem que inventar
coisas ideias
que façam sentido dentro do nosso fluxo
dentro da nossa lógica de movimento
porque é o nosso trabalho que tem que se
adaptar a quem nós somos e nós não somos
nós que temos que adaptar o trabalho
uma outra coisa que o a matéria prima do
nosso trabalho fala em trabalho
entretenimento festival de música pra
gente é muito importante a matéria prima
de onde a gente vai pesquisar informação
sobre cultura comportamento consumo
mercado saiu do nosso território fixo
nos permitiu conhecer mais de 40
festivais no último ano e isso nos deu
um background uma robustez de formação
de conteúdo para o que a gente pode
oferecer para os nossos clientes e para
os nossos alunos de uma forma que a
gente nunca teria se identificasse em
casa pela internet fazendo pesquisa e
por fim quando eu falei que o
experimento de trabalhar e viver no
fluxo
eu não vou entrar em muitos detalhes mas
eu posso afirmar que para um casal
dormia em 104 camas diferente durante um
ano e meio é bastante saudável
ano passado eu comecei a compartilhar
essas reflexões de estar no lugar tem
outro na nas redes sociais com essa
hashtag que aprendemos em casa e aí
vários amigos começaram a compartilhar
marcar outros amigos falar que legal e
interessante e aí o dia na conversa de
what's up da minha mãe falou é porque
essas pessoas estão tão interessadas na
minha vida que eu tô fazendo que é tão
diferente da vida delas que está
despertando nelas esse interesse
e essa vontade de ler essas pequenas
reflexões e ela fosse pra mim a você que
nos tira do nosso lugar comum você nos
faz pensar em coisas e impossibilidades
e ver as coisas do nosso dia a dia de
uma forma que a gente nunca tinha visto
vocês não foi você não faz pensar que é
possível a gente vê as coisas de outra
forma
eu queria pedir para vocês fecharem olho
pelo novo por um segundo
e se depois de tudo isso que eu falei eu
queria pedir para vocês pensarem nas
infinitas possibilidades que a palavra
casa pode ter daqui pra frente pra vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]